Wickham in buckinghamshire a Tory Shire
of the south east and for so long a safe
Suburban seat
but this a constituency where the Creed
of conservatism could be losing
believers
Wickham could be a real lighthouse
constituency in the next general
election this is Tory territory and
people here have voted for the
conservative since the early
1950s think of it if you like as the
Tory blue wall just like Boris Johnson
took down Labor's red wall in its
heartlands in the 2019 general election
people are wondering now can kiss Dharma
begin to take chunks out of the blue
wall which stretches from here in the
Tory shires right down to the southern
coast so I'm a director at Ugo in the
qualitative team to judge how possible
that might be I came to observe a focus
group conducted by pollsters yougov with
some questions of my own hands up if you
think we need a change of government
trust issues lack of plans
you know all of that is what what I see
whenever I hear conservative word that
comes to mind is stale I've been there
too long now the current crisis
emphasizes that our government is fairly
broken this room of floating voters with
the cost of living in the budget on
their minds you have no option now but
to shopping places that are cheaper
or all cut back I've had to change my
hours at work because of child care
costs so I can't afford to work
full-time anymore it's not feasible for
our family so I've had to write my mum
in to do child care but she's retired it
feels a bit unfair but I have no option
I can't afford to work otherwise yeah my
kids are the same way I mean it is it's
impossible really because I wouldn't say
we're a low earning family it's just
that's just that's the way it is now
yeah I came off a fixed tariff in
January but I've been on for two years
when I come off it I went bloody nor you
really you know the jump was you know
quite immense my daughter and her have
been trying to move out to here and the
house prices are just ridiculous I wrote
to conservative a long time I've always
supported them and then I got a bit
tired of
forests and the promises we need to have
some results and I want to see some
improvements some real positive like
cost of living for me that's what's key
to people everything's very short-term
because of the way it's a five-year
cycle there's no real long-term strategy
for investment and it it's just caused
all these problems that five-year cycle
soon Ended as a general election looms
large Steve Baker the the current MP
what could he say to persuade you that
he's the man to look after this area
actually
because he's been there so long because
this has always been a conservative area
he just sort of oh well that's all right
they'll vote for me I think he had a
real shock at the last election when the
then labor candidate came close to
overturning his majority the
conservatives in seats like this will
hope to avoid that sort of shock at the
next general election who's going to win
the next election
this a group agreed that conservative
PMS of recent months did the party
little favors hear a trail of trust that
the people put into them and also a
sense of hypocrisy in everything they do
when they tell people how to behave and
what they should be doing and then how
they have behaved as well that's a key
word for me trust I was going to say I
trusted them a long time and then you
get so many mistakes you're just like
you know what I'm hearing but
uncertainty too about Rishi sunak I
don't know why I don't trust him but I
don't
um
it's a terrible thing to say but it's
two uh that's freaky so it's
disingenuous yes we all know that you
know the conservatives are is a broken
ship and for him to be going in there
and
pretending to try and save it I think is
disingenuous I don't think it's savable
is this new legislation he's trying to
bring in about uh people who uh illegal
immigrants coming over by boat and if
they'd land in this country get caught
um they're never going to be able to
claim Asylum here written on front the
front of the paper is we don't think
this is going to get through
international law or whatever phrase was
used
how can we support someone who is
putting forward such ideas that are
patently just never ever okay okay but
you're not trying they're what they're
doing is they're making big
announcements to divert from the problem
the problem is that they don't have a
system for dealing with immigrants which
is why immigrants which do come over
here sometime today when they shouldn't
they need to fix the system in here
instead of wasting Millions diverting
two main parties with different policies
and plans but this group not yet wholly
convinced by either how would you
describe the current labor party and
what it stands for
the labor party
wants to
consolidate its lead in the polls it's
got to start developing if you want a
personality a sense of what it is
um and why give people a reason for
voting for it rather than
I'm not voting to Tori I will vote labor
it's not a reason to vote for labor
there's a reason to vote not or not vote
for the conservative yeah yeah In
fairness they they had they have said
that they've got these policies but
we're not going to release them yet I
think what
brings for me he brings that
I don't want to be at the front I don't
want everyone here talking about me I
want to lead a party and I want someone
that I don't want to wake up in the
morning and see them on the front page
every day I think personality politics
is very dangerous you shouldn't be
voting for a person because he's nice we
don't just want a personality we do want
to party and it's the policies we should
never be voting just for a person
a general election a while off yet but
the mood of Voters here offer a taster
of the challenges for both parties as
labor tries to gain ground and the
Tories try to hold them off the campaign
already very much on Beth Rigby Sky News
Wycombe